Hola Yo soy Natalia Cabrera parada y
esto es aquí América el magacín de
France 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias y las historias de nuestro
continente y esto es lo que veremos hoy
en búsqueda de estabilidad durante su
último año de mandato y en medio de la
ola de renuncias de sus aliados el
presidente de México Andrés Manuel López
Obrador dio un ultimátum a quienes
busquen apartarse de sus cargos para
buscar la nominación de morena a la
presidencia el partido del mandatario ha
arrasado en las últimas elecciones por
lo que el aspirante oficialista es en la
práctica el favorito
La regulación del uso recreativo de la
marihuana en Colombia avanza el debate
fue aplazado en el senado debido a
discusiones entre los legisladores pero
la iniciativa nunca había avanzado tanto
traería control sobre un mercado ilegal
ya existente en el país sudamericano
y buenas noticias en Perú El Congreso
rechazó un proyecto de ley que buscaba
imponer límites a la libertad de
expresión la ley mordaza buscaba
endurecer las penas por los delitos de
difamación y calumnia en el código penal
hablamos con periodistas en Lima
y vamos de inmediato a México donde esta
semana Hubo mucho movimiento en el
gobierno debido a la carrera por la
candidatura del partido del presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador a la
presidencia de Morena en las elecciones
de 2024 morena gobierna 21 estados de
los 32 del país Por lo cual quien que
denominado arranca prácticamente como el
favorito para hacer el presidente una de
las figuras clave del gabinete del
canciller Marcelo ebrard renunció a su
cargo para hacer campaña por la
candidatura así lo anunciaba el
secretario de relaciones exteriores
[Música]
solicitar y presentar mi renuncia a la
secretaría de relaciones exteriores
con un propósito de dedicarme de lleno
con alegría y resolución a defender el
proyecto que encabeza nuestro presidente
el presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador en toda la república mexicana
en su lugar ASUME Alicia bárcena
embajadora de México en chile y quien
durante 14 años estuvo al frente de la
cepal por otro lado la jefa de gobierno
de la Ciudad de México la capital
Claudia sheinbaum también dejó el cargo
para buscar la nominación y convertirse
en la primera mujer en llegar al Zócalo
escuchemos lo que dijo en su acto de
despedida al que acudieron cerca de
80.000 personas
continuidad
con sello propio
a la gran obra de transformación
iniciada por el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador gracias al pueblo de la
Ciudad de México por permitirme servirle
gracias a este pueblo
solidario y recíproco como pocos
vamos ahora a un encuentro con el pueblo
de México
con la convicción
de que la cuarta transformación tendrá
continuidad y de que es tiempo de las
mujeres
son alrededor de ocho miembros del
gabinete los que amlo tiene que relevar
el secretario de gobierno Adán López
cargo que equivale al de jefe de
gabinete así como la jefatura de la
procuraduría Federal del consumidor del
instituto de seguridad social y la
secretaría de energía entre otros
también el líder de la mayoría en el
senado Ricardo Monreal dio un paso al
costado para buscar la candidatura de
morena ante las renuncias el presidente
López Obrador dio un plazo para evitar
más cambios futuros e inestabilidad en
su último año al mando en 2024 no sólo
se renovará en la presidencia y las dos
cámaras del congreso Federal también
están en juego nueve gubernaturas
incluida la de Ciudad de México y varias
alcaldías Morena arrasó en las
elecciones regionales de principios de
junio arrebatando estados que
históricamente habían sido gobernados
por el partido revolucionario
institucional el pri
y vamos a Estados Unidos donde también
se sigue moviendo la carrera de la
presidencia y se suman aspirantes para
arrebatarle la nominación republicana
del expresidente Donald Trump esta
semana el alcalde de Miami Francis
Suárez lanzó su candidatura y es el
primer hispano en hacerlo Suárez ha sido
crítico tanto con Trump como con el que
tiene más opciones para quitarle la
nominación al Magnate el gobernador de
Florida roundís el corresponsal de
France 24 en Miami antonibel chino se
amplía sobre su trayectoria
el alcalde de la ciudad de Miami Francis
Suárez se suma a la carrera para las
elecciones presidenciales de Estados
Unidos a través de un vídeo publicado en
sus redes sociales el político de 45
años ha confirmado que busca la
nominación del partido de repúblicano
para ser el candidato de los comicios de
2024 Suárez es alcalde de la ciudad de
Miami desde 2017 fue elegido Por poco
más de 22.000 votos y en 2021 fue
reelegido por una cifra similar pero
desde que ocupó la oficina de la
alcaldía trajo la atención de todo el
país cuando por ejemplo impulsó
políticas para convertir esta ciudad en
la que Residen unos 450.000 habitantes
en la capital del bitcoin llegando a
asegurar que gracias al mercado de las
criptomonedas los residentes no pagarían
impuestos algo que no ha sido así
también impulsó su propia moneda digital
La Miami Coin que se devaluó más del 95%
prácticamente sin valor también durante
la pandemia aprovechó para vender Miami
como el lugar idóneo para residir
diciendo que aquí no se pagaban tantos
impuestos como en Nueva York o
California y tratando que grandes
empresas de silicon Valley se mudaran a
este lugar esto provocó que muchos
residentes de esos estados se mudaran
aumentando los precios de las
propiedades en más del 50% y provocando
una grave crisis de vivienda además se
sabe que el FBI lo está investigando por
un supuesto pago de 170 mil dólares por
ayudar a un desarrollador a construir en
una zona no algo que sería completamente
ilegal la candidatura de Francia Suárez
ha recibido críticas de compañeros de su
partido el congresista republicano
Carlos Jiménez que fue alcalde del
Condado de Miami de que abarca una mayor
población que la de la ciudad ha dicho
que no votará por él porque es un
completo fraude que votó por los
demócratas hillary Clinton y Joe biden y
también por el candidato demócrata a la
gobernación de Florida el partido de
republicano tiene ya varios
precandidatos que están buscando
oficialmente la nominación incluyendo el
expresidente Donald Trump el gran
favorito según las encuestas el
gobernador de Florida ron de santis El
exgobernador de Nueva Jersey Chris
Christi y el ex vicepresidente Mike
pence entre otros
Trump no solo enfrenta el desafío de los
otros integrantes de su partido sino que
su paso a la historia como el primer
presidente en ser imputado con cargos
federales por haber llevado documentos
confidenciales a sus residencia privada
en Florida
podría impactarlo en las encuestas lo
que a su vez podría influir en si se
queda o no con la nominación republicana
y se enfrenta a Joe biden en noviembre
de 2024 según una encuesta de ABC e
ipsos si bien la mayoría de los
republicanos considera que no es una
acusación seria y que tiene motivos
políticos hay una pequeña minoría de
conservadores que cree que sí lo que
crea una profunda polarización en el
partido y dicha minoría ha ido en
aumento en los últimos meses con lo cual
lo que pase en el proceso podría definir
su apoyo al ex mandatario nos vamos a
Colombia La regulación de la venta y
producción de marihuana está a un debate
de ser aprobada por el senado se trata
de un paso histórico y sus promotores
aseguran que ayudaría el consumo
responsable y contrarrestaría el
narcotráfico el camino para llegar a
este punto ha sido largo y se ha
extendido por décadas Manuela Cano nos
explica
el camino para la legalización de la
marihuana en Colombia ha sido largo y
complejo en 1986 la ley 30 que adopta el
estatuto Nacional de estupefacientes
Reguló el uso de la marihuana
estableció la dosis para consumo
personal de Cannabis en máximo 20 gramos
la legislación además permitía el
cultivo de 20 plantas
en 1994 el gobierno despenalizó la
posesión y el uso personal de la
marihuana pero no su comercialización
el país sudamericano también abrió paso
al uso terapéutico de la planta en 2016
la marihuana medicinal fue legalizada su
uso puede ser autorizado por una receta
médica el entonces ministro de salud de
Colombia Alejandro Gaviria defendía así
el paso que daría la nación da un cambio
cultural que se está dando en todas
partes que obliga a actualizar nuestras
leyes y que obliga a cambiar la forma
como se ha regulado el consumo en
particular el consumo de marihuana
medicinal entonces de alguna manera
Colombia se está poniendo a Tono con el
mundo desde entonces los intentos de
legalizar su venta y producción se han
multiplicado sus Defensores aseguran que
sería un cambio de paradigma en el país
por un lado argumentan que se trata de
una manera de propiciar un consumo
responsable además de reducir el acceso
a sustancias consideradas más peligrosas
como la cocaína y la heroína
y por el otro señalan que ayudaría a
combatir el narcotráfico en uno de los
principales países productores de
marihuana en el mundo la política
prohibicionista ha encarecido un
producto que sin control Estatal ha
enriquecido y potencializado
organizaciones criminales que siguen en
expansión en el mundo sus garantías
estimadas por última vez en 2009 eran de
84 mil millones de dólares anuales la
regularización sin embargo ha tenido
grandes detractores que alegan que su
consumo acarrea problemas de salud y que
legalizarla promocionaría su consumo en
Perú Hay buenas noticias para los
periodistas una polémica ley que buscaba
Elevar la pena privativa de la libertad
a los delitos de difamación y calumnia
no obtuvo la mayoría en el congreso la
norma fue criticada por instituciones
peruanas que denunciaron que grupos
poderosos pretendían amedrentarlos el
corresponsal de France 24 en Lima
Francisco Zacarías tiene el reporte
el juzgado de origen el juzgado el
periodista Daniel llovera asiste a una
audiencia virtual de la justicia peruana
magistrados que tengan mucho cuidado con
lo que señala el creyente los quiere
sorprender la Corte Suprema después de
absolverlo en un caso de difamación
decidió reabrir su causa hay periodistas
como yo que afrontamos juicios por
supuesta difamación cosa que nosotros
rechazamos no no reconocemos por lo
menos los que hemos investigado aspectos
relacionados a la organización llamadas
o alisio de Vida Cristiana casos como el
de Daniel llovera se habrían agravado
con prisión efectiva de haber sido
ratificada la ley que elevaba cuatro
años de cárcel los delitos y difamación
y calumnia muchos la iniciativa conocida
como la hemorrasa tenía la intención de
perseguir a periodistas que la prensa
nos ataque que nos siga atacando pero
quienes insisten en impulsar la norma
afirman que solo buscan defender los
derechos de los ciudadanos no es una ley
mordaza es la ley que protege
salvaguarda el honor la buena reputación
de todos los peruanos y aparte de ello
la intimidad personal que no está
tipificado en el código penal recién
vamos a incluirlo esta nota tiene que
estar lista a las nueve y treinta porque
sale como cabecera de la tanda los
medios de comunicación consideran que el
objetivo de esta ley era presionar a los
periodistas como represalia sus
incómodas denuncias e investigaciones
creo que es un evidente maltrato a la
prensa a la libertad de prensa
especialmente es un riesgo que corremos
todos los periodistas que hacemos
investigación y que hacemos denuncias a
las al poder político básicamente en los
últimos cinco años cerca de 150
periodistas han sido llevados a
tribunales medios afirman que en Perú
existe una tendencia de algunos
gobiernos para controlar o callar al
periodismo
y para la despedida regresamos a México
donde una ola de calor que se predice se
prolongará durante 15 días
ha generado Que las temperaturas superen
los 45 grados Celsius se trata de la
tercera ola de calor de 2023 y ha
obligado a los habitantes de la ciudad
de México a buscar refugio en la sombra
por las inusuales altas temperaturas en
la capital que está a más de 2000 metros
de altitud entre tanto en el norte del
país en la frontera con Estados Unidos
también se está registrando la ola de
calor que podría superar las
temperaturas de 45 grados Gracias por
ver esta emisión de aquí América en la
producción estuvieron Christian Vargas y
Jennifer Guevara Sigan viendo France 24
y France 24.com
[Música]